one other thing most entrepreneurs
forget about is the fact that the most
important product that we sell is not
software it's not technology it's not
real estate insurance pharmaceutical
says the most important product that you
and I sell are people and the people who
study people and understand people the
best typically end up excellent to the
highest level of any company they're
part of because they understand people
so when you look at people there's
typically four different types of people
I call it star the challenge with most
of us is most of us only view the world
through our lens it's only our lens
because we do have a personality type
now let me explain you to four different
types of personalities S stands for
structures now structured people just so
you know extremely organized they're
about systems they like to work with
people who have won before so they're
not coming from a place that they're
saying something and they don't have
credibility you can work with an S
unless you say sit in the car with an S
you're driving there to passenger-side
this is what they'll typically do
they'll typically look at your car and
see stains of a water bottle there and
still see seat issues over here see a
couple stains your windows not clean
your cars not clean in their mind then
in their mind they don't think you're
sufficient efficient enough because you
are not at their level of being
organized s is typically tend to look at
everybody else that they can't be as
good as me and nobody can do it as good
as me understanding how they think is
very critical
T's is for technically a technical
person is typically someone who they're
very analytical they want to know
everything about the product you're
selling they want to know all the
details they want to know all the stuff
that you know you have they look at you
as do you understand the concepts are
you very competent on what you're
talking about if you're not you lose
them with T's A's or action-oriented
these are guys that are typically loud
life at a party you put them somewhere
to network with everybody will talk to
people very competitive they love sports
you know their energy typically is out
there and people sometimes they rub
people the wrong way that's a
and then you have a relationship which
is our relationship folks they love
listening they love hugging they love
kisses they love gifts
they love being nice to them their their
dirt
they're great with relationships they're
great with people typically and our is
very good if they're doing business and
building relationship with somebody in
your company that they're dealing with
but understanding these four
personalities becomes this challenge is
if you are an S you need to know who you
annoy and you need to know how to
communicate with those people
if you're an AR you need to know your
weaknesses and your strengths because
the reality of it is if you look at all
four R's get offended very easily ace
get very bored easily teased get annoyed
easily and SS just don't think anybody
can can be as good as them unless if
they're another s that's how they think
so one running a business if let's just
say you're one of them and you're not
strong onto our side you can't
necessarily go and become very good as
an AR you can simply go hire somebody
who's an art to do that part for you if
you're not very technically you can hire
a technical person if you're not very
action or you can go hire somebody is
very competitive on the sales side to do
very well but regardless a very strong
company a very strong team typically has
somebody with all of these personalities
together to take the company to the next
level and you want it to advance to the
next level it will come down to you
understanding yourself and understanding
the people that you work with your
customers who you work with once you
learn that business sales leading become
so easy because you understand people
and I have on my website I have this
whole thing written out type that you
can go out there you know get the PDF
the link on the bottom it's called the
start personality it tells you which one
of these need what when they're being
led and how they lead as well as how to
work with them now legs should be on the
bottom for you to go out there and look
at printed out share with your people
and if you have any questions comment on
the bottom thanks for watching
you